[Norvig] We're in this range where we might be done but we're not quite sure.
Our computers can do about a billion instructions per second
or so on a good second--
that is, one where they're not wasting part of the second with a page fault or a cache miss.
If the answer had turned out to be in the millions, we could say, "Oh, great. We're done."
If it had turned out to be in the trillions, we could say, "It's totally infeasible."
"We need a better solution."
But if it's somewhere in the middle with the billions,
then we're not quite sure.
We better try to refine the result a little bit to tell if this brute force approach is going to work.
And think of the space of solutions in terms of execution time as like a contour map.
And here deep down in the valley where there's only millions of computations needed,
millions of instructions needed to complete the answer, then we're really happy
because we know that's going to go really fast.
And outside of the happy valley there are these high peaks
where we have trillions of computations needed,
and there we're going to be sad.
If we're stuck out in these domains,
we're going to have to somehow find a path back in
because we can't just go ahead and calculate when we're out at the trillions.
And in the middle here where we need billions of instructions to complete our computation,
then we're not quite sure.
So maybe we're happy here and we can stay in this domain.
Maybe we want to find our path through the wilderness back into the happy valley.
It depends on the problem.
And we're going to try to look at problems in terms of this space,
try to find our way back in, but know when to stop when we've got close enough.
Now let's keep thinking about what it means to do an assignment.
Try to get just a little bit more concrete about it.
If we want to assign red to house number 1,
let's think about the ways in which we could implement that.
Here's 1 possibility where we say we're going to have an array of houses.
We take number 1 and we add red to its set of properties.
That means that each house is represented as a set.
Here's another possibility where we take house number 1,
we set its color property equal to red.
Here each house would have to be represented as a user-defined custom class
which had properties for color and nationality and so on.
Here's a third possibility.
We have a variable called red,
and we just assign that the number 1.
So here we were assigning properties to houses,
and in this one we're assigning houses to properties.
I want you to check all the approaches that you think would be reasonable designs
for implementing assignment.